blackrock which is uh the the what's
amazing to me now is the uh
the
and we've been following this i spoke to
mullen about it when i was in new york
and he made some great points about
corporate landlords just owning
everything in america individual
landlords
uh disappearing people
not having to pay their rent so then a
lot of these landlords have to sell
their properties
and then um
you know who comes in and buys blackrock
blackrock
or blackstone same
thing right
um
blackstone buys 12
000
uh sun belt apartments for 5.8 billion
dollars
um
this is from zero hedge wall street
won't rest until it becomes the biggest
and perhaps only
landlord in the u.s
on wednesday blackstone cemented its
position as america's largest
residential and commercial landlord by
buying uh apartment owner preferred
apartment communities in a deal valued
at 5.8 billion
demonstrating the unstoppable investor
demand for multi-family
i.e rental properties in sun belt
states
according to wall street journal
blackstone will pay 25 a share in cash
for the atlanta-based real estate
investment trust
that that represents a premium of
roughly 39 percent over the closing
price on february the 9th the day
uh before bloomberg news reported the
reit was exploring options including a
sale
so the deal includes more than 40 uh
rental apartment properties including 12
000 units in states uh including florida
tennessee and georgia that's what they
mean by sun belt preferred apartment
also owns 54 grocery anchored shopping
centers anchored by grocery stores
probably like publix
about 70 of the deal's value is in its
rental apartments wow
so black stone
now they're ramping up its bet on u.s
rental housing blackstone i want you to
think about this is fun we like we like
we like to read the article and go huh
why is this this keeps falling down here
i keep i keep adjusting this and it
doesn't matter it just keeps
um
so listen to this blackstone has been
aggressively
ramping
up its bet on u.s rental housing the
firm has agreed to buy two other
companies that own apartments in the
past two months building up his presence
in states including colorado texas
arizona and
georgia well what do they mean by that
ramping up
its bet
on u.s rental
housing well they're betting
and they're correct
that people are not gonna be able to own
homes or that more people
in the future
are going to rent
this is their bet
and they're probably correct
because the cost of home ownership in
this country
is
i mean
ludicrous
especially in places where you'd want to
live
so companies like blackstone go
listen the future
is going to be
the gig economy
where you have people that hop from gig
to gig
and they're going to be permanent
renters
and that's what it's going to be they're
not going to own property they may not
even own a car
they're going to use services like uber
and lyft and
they're going to rent an apartment
they're not going to own much of
anything and according to that article
you're gonna love it you're gonna be
happy and you know the american dream is
is is uh turning from
home ownership and family to something
else entirely
it's really what it's becoming it used
to be the american dream as as stated
now
you know the
how possible it was and
you know whether it was legit then
certainly more legit seeming than now
yes of course it didn't include
everything but what about non-binary
poets i know yes i know that that's
yes thank you
they were left out
but the american dream it was a family
and property kind of right community
based on those things family property
you own property
you have a family you're in a community
there's industry the community thrives
everybody kind of
succeeds together fails together there's
an investment there are social
commitments things are more local now
things are global
you don't have a family everybody lives
in a city everybody's alone
everybody's unonly fans flicking their
bean
everybody's taking multiple pills just
to get out of bed in the morning and
then another round of pills just to get
back into bed at night
people are severed from their community
they're severed
from any social commitments
the only communities they're a part of
are digital communities that are
incredibly toxic
that are centered around overthrowing
the government or owning a picture of an
ape
but life has changed the american dream
has changed
and blackstone gets this they know where
we're going they're not dummies
they can see it they go how the hell
they can afford this
they're gonna rent and they'll be happy
to do it
people go why do i need a home i don't
have a family
you know
what do i need a home you know i have
houses and i don't really need houses
but they're good investments and
i like houses and i certainly have
friends over but i don't
i don't need a house because i don't
have a family so i don't
need a house but i guess nobody needs
anything but the reason to have it like
ben and his wife always remind me that i
don't need
a home they always go you don't need to
live in a house you don't have a family
because they're heterosexuals so they're
gonna have a family so it means they
deserve a house so i should give my
house to them
i have multiple homes i should give them
all to them but that's the point
because i don't need it as a gay guy
who's single i don't need square footage
i don't need space
i'm to give it to them
uh well no
they can get it they can get their own
but i'm always constantly told i don't
need a house and they're they're they're
they're right to that to an extent
because i don't have a family
but that is why most people buy houses
so as families
um
you know family formation is low and
it's happening later in life people just
don't need to buy [ __ ] houses now
you've brought up an interesting chart
here the national rent index up 18
year over year why don't you tell the
people
about this chart that you've
brought up so why are you laughing
i didn't i didn't ever say you didn't
eat at home you and your wife have
constantly
i've never said that you've constantly
if a house has like seven bedrooms
before i'm like i don't think you need
seven bedrooms i think i've said that
but i don't think i've said but it's
it's because
yes it is
you've made me feel bad
for being gay
and you've said that gay people don't
deserve homes well gay people a lot of
us have more money than you as a
straight person
because if you didn't
meet me you'd be working uh tilling the
land
i don't know what the hell you'd be
doing but gay people have higher than
average incomes and they're creative but
you're telling me what if i want to
adopt kids what if i want to adopt uh
uh children
i'm for that to fill the rooms buy the
space and and fill the rooms now if i
adopted a child
would i could you get it for me and
figure it out yeah it's a long process
though you need literally how involved
do i have to be
i read a book about it it's a problem
why didn't you read a book about it it
was in a you read a book about gay
adoption no not gay adoption but just
adoption in general yeah it was
in bubba watson's book he's a pga tour
player he talks about adopting kids and
it took him a long time yeah it took
even bubble watson he's got tons of
money he's a millionaire he had to get
on planes isn't he drunk though no no
he's sober he's dead sober oh who's the
drunk who loves trump uh john daly yeah
because him i get they go let's give it
a take a beast before we give you a kid
but so it's i've always heard this that
adoption is very hard that's my whole
thing with abortion
abort and i'm for abort but i'm like
listen maybe we make adoption easier so
that it's not we're not putting these
kids in uh mills
right
it's a nice time out for the woman nine
months nice time out you get to eat
whatever you want
sit on the bed put her on the
tempur-pedic get her a tub of ice cream
and then give the kid to somebody who
can't have it i always thought that was
the way to do it give her some pickles
you know they get weird cravings give
her pickles a tub of rocky road pop the
baby out and then give it to a family
but why is it so hard to adopt a kid
i i think everything is about
i hate to say and i don't want to sound
like a paranoid person but it's really
all about it's all sex trafficking no
it's it's
it's what it seems it's it's true it's
like
cps the child protective services
is like and i want to have a eliza blue
on the uh human trafficking do you
follow her i want to know if she knows
anything about this cps because they're
they're they're crazy what they do they
just take kids and then you know they go
you know they nobody knows what happens
to the kids but they they take them out
of these situations that are supposedly
bad and i'm not saying that all of these
situations aren't bad but these kids end
up in foster care and in the link
between that and trafficking it's crazy
but i think we need to make adoption
easier but what i'm saying about uh this
is when you
guilt me and you attack me and say you
don't because you've said multiple times
to me when i had my mansion in palm
springs or my my uh big big uh kind of
like a mini mansion in the valley and
you were like oh you don't need this but
i told you a million [ __ ] times i
want to have a christmas party with
logan paul and barry weiss that's the
whole [ __ ] point of having the square
footage is to is to have a party with
everyone and and you do and you demean
i'm just saying i don't want to be
demeaned
tell them about the rental chart so it
says here that uh like if you look at
the chart here 2020 to 2021 it was down
1.4 percent but then 21 to 2022 up 17.8
percent united states annual rent growth
yeah more people are gonna be renting
from here on out that seems to be the
case yeah it's gonna be you know we shut
it down
uh we destroyed people's ability to earn
a living and earn income we [ __ ] up
people's credit
you know it we we
we stopped
you know a lot of forward momentum that
people had in their lives